after days of being raked over the rocks
for promising to spend taxpayer money on
crack pipes the biden administration is
denying that the policy
ever existed at all
hhs just put out a statement clarifying
around some reports
that crack pipes or not would be part of
the safe smoking kits that are funded by
the administration
but can you clarify for us
were they never a part of the kit or
were they removed in response to this
reporting and this push back
they were never a part of the kit it was
inaccurate reporting and we wanted to
put out information to make that clear
they were never part of the kit saki
says the administration never planned to
buy the pipes
which is different from what the
department of health and human services
told us
they never denied that they had planned
to buy the pipes they just said that now
quote no federal funding will be used
directly or through subsequent
reimbursement of grantees to put pipes
in safe smoking kits before that biden's
allies actually defended the free crack
pipes as a logical part of any harm
reduction plan three different stories
who's telling the truth
it's actually pretty simple to find out
you pretty much just need to google
safe smoking kit and harm reduction plan
and then this is the important part
limit the search dates to a few days
a few days ago when the biden
administration changed the definition
and started gaslighting everybody so on
the search day you go from the dawn of
time until three four days ago before
all the craziness and all the changes
now what is a harm reduction plan what
is a safe smoking kit when you do that
one of the very first articles that pops
up is from the maryland capital gazette
there at the very top is a picture of a
safe smoking kit and and right there
quite prominent is a crack pipe
according to the article
there was backlash just like we're
seeing now and the county stopped
distributing the kits
you don't even need to look at the
countless descriptions of safe smoking
kits that mention crack pipes it's right
there in the name by definition a
smoking kit cannot be a smoking kit if
it does not include anything through
which to smoke
this is
gas lighting plain and simple just like
15 days to slow the spread just life
like the safe and effective vaccines
that stop infection and transmission
just like joe rogan the right wing
extremist
it's establishment gaslighting
and they might get away with it i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday from matt
who says why is michael knowles an
absolute meme
the man has literally written himself
into the united states congressional
record this is true thank you well i
didn't write myself in it was actually
congressman paul gosar who did because
as we have mentioned before on this show
i mentioned offhandedly that i will not
vote for any federal candidates and you
should not either who do not promise to
investigate
dr fauci and zero out his salary this is
called the michael knowles public health
protection pledge dozens of candidates
have signed on it's now been entered as
a house resolution your congressmen your
senators can sign on as co-sponsors of
this resolution they should you should
bug them to do it tag your congressman
tell them to stand up
go against dr fauci help preserve
self-government sign on to the pledge
very very important to protecting our
country when you want to protect not
just your country but your identity i
would strongly recommend you check out
lifelock fake charities are becoming
more prevalent and an easy way for
scammers to steal your money and your
identity to prevent yourself from
falling victim always research
organizations before donating watch out
for emails with links to fake websites
and never give out bank account
information or your social security
number it's important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could steal
what's yours sometimes even harm your
finances or your credit good thing
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats like your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect your information
has been compromised
they will send you an alert no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton
join right now save up to 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com
knowles that's lifelock.com knowles for
25
off
it's the gas lighting that is so
offensive to me
it it's not just
that the biden administration peddles
crack pipes
it's not even just
that they lie about it
it's that they're forcing all of us to
lie about it too
they expect all of us it's not just yeah
it was a dumb policy you know it's no no
we never did that in the first place
what are you talking about it's a safe
smoke it's a safe smoking kit a safe
smoking kit includes crack includes
crack pipes
no it doesn't
it doesn't include anything through
which to smoke well then how's it a
smoking kit
never mind you don't know what you're
talking about you're a misinformer
you're spreading fake news
the gas lighting has been turned up to
11. the clearest example of the
gaslighting
is joe rogan
the rogan controversy is kind of dying
down right now
that the cancel mob seems to be pulling
off spotify says they're going to stick
by rogue and they've already gotten a
lot of concessions disclaimers on his
right wing episodes they took down over
100 episodes
right they say you've got to have more
democrats on your show okay fine
the the premise here was that joe rogan
is some kind of far right radical
extremist
not only is joe rogan not a far-right
extremist
he's not even a centrist really he's not
even
a center leftist he is a
pretty well established leftist person
who just happens to have a couple of
views that contradict
the liberal establishment there's a guy
matt orffilea
who put together
a two or three minute compilation of all
that all that right-wing extremism from
from joe rogan take a listen
i really believe that michelle obama
runs she wins she's good she's great
she's the wife of the best president
that we've had in our lifetime i've
never voted right wing in my life i
consider universal basic income a really
good idea i want free college education
take it easy hello bernie how are you
joe wonderful pleasure to meet you nice
to meet you i like tulsi and i like
bernie that's it oh yeah everybody else
can eat [ __ ] look at you progressive
yeah i think i'll probably vote for
bernie i think he's looking out for the
interests of the working people and i
think he wants people to have a better
life and do better and i'm all for that
and if that means i have to pay more
intact like people think oh you're a
socialist i've heard people say that oh
your socialist bro like first of all
he's not even a socialist
he's a democratic socialist it's a
different thing i would like to spend
more in taxes if they could fix inner
city communities and and take these poor
neighborhoods
spend more you [ __ ] promise
87 of scientists said that human
activity is driving global warming i'm
very pro-choice i'm very women's rights
civil rights gay rights trans rights
this goes on for minutes more you get
the picture
not exactly a right-wing extremist
joe rogan
is as clearly on the left as anybody
he just
questioned dr fauci like twice and that
was enough
for the establishment to say he's a far
right radical he's he's he's to the
right of hitler he this guy this guy is
he's a nazi he's so
you say well actually the nazis weren't
totally on the right now never mind no
it doesn't matter forget about that
joe rogan is a threat we've got a stop
he's he's he's an insurrectionist it's
going to be the next thing they say
about it
it shows you the the power of the
gaslighting not only the audacity to do
it we all know it's not true it's not as
though joe rogan's a minor cultural
figure he's the most popular podcaster
in the world and yet they're they are
urinating on our legs they are telling
us that it is raining we we have heard
joe rogan say all these things over the
years and now they're trying to convince
us that he's francisco franco and that's
the most offensive part that's the most
it's not even the incompetence and and
the the lies necessarily it's like it's
the it's the lies about the lies
it's this culture of lies that we're all
all being steeped in you want to you
want to talk about gaslighting what's
going on right now
not just in the united states not even
just up in america's hat with the
truckers and the freedom convoy but now
what's going on in europe the freedom
convoy has made it to continental europe
it's now in france this is the largest
workers movement that i have seen in my
lifetime probably the largest
movement of workers political movement
of workers
in a hundred years
and the left is completely against it
this freedom convoy
has left a whole bunch of cities around
france
specifically in southern france and is
headed up to paris they're part of this
convoy what are they protesting they're
protesting the country's mandatory covid
vaccine program
this is a direct outgrowth of the canada
freedom convoy they're even calling it
the same term it's the freedom convoy
this is according to the new york times
you've got you've got reporting there
saying yep this is directly coming out
of the worker movement in canada this
from reuters one of the truck drivers
said we're just tired of it all we want
to go where we want without being asked
for a vaccine pass at least with this
action i am doing something this is the
voice of
actual marginalized people
when i say marginalized people i do not
mean ibram candy i do not mean robin
d'angelo i do not mean
radicals aton easy coats not radical
identitarians
in
ivory towers or on television talking
about actual normal people doing jobs
bringing our goods to us from city to
city keep the lifeblood of the economy
who just want to be able to go get a
beer without having to show their
medical history
and the left is completely
against them
and so what are we being told
this isn't the working class
this isn't ordinary people this is it no
th this is fascists
bigot racists everyone they don't like
is a racist this is
terr do not pay any attention to this
yeah we support workers but don't look
at any of those actual workers this is
no just listen to dr fauci and rochelle
walensky and the world economic forum
they're re they're the voice of the
oppressed they're the voice of the
workers forget the actual
truckers
and why are they why are they rallying
by the way
why are it's not
because they're racist
it's not because they're fascist it's
not it's it's a very simple reason why
are they rallying because they don't
want to have to inject themselves with
an experimental drug to
s to sort of try to stave off a cough
that that
it's not actually going to work to do
even according to the cdc even according
to
the fda even according to dr fauci and
all the rest of them
it's all about
the vaccines and why why might an
ordinary person be skeptical of the
covid vaccines well because we're being
told that the vaccines are extremely
safe and extremely effective and that's
why you need to go get your first
vaccine shot and also we're being told
they're not effective at all which is
why you've got to get your fourth or
fifth vaccine shot and
maybe the the genius elites don't don't
understand that there's a contradiction
there but ordinary people do and they've
had enough of it
they're we're finally getting a little
light on this whole situation
and when you want to control the light
in your home i would strongly recommend
you check out hunter douglas who doesn't
love to live well to be perfectly at
ease in comfort and style hunter douglas
can help you do just that with their
innovative window shade designs gorgeous
fabrics and control systems so advanced
they can be scheduled to automatically
adjust to their optimal position
throughout the day
perhaps it's the way the shades diffuse
harsh sunlight to cast a beautiful glow
across the room or being able to enjoy
the view outside the window while
protecting your privacy inside the house
maybe it's the superior insulation that
the shades provide keeping you warmer in
winter cooler in summer and lowering
utility bills i didn't realize
until i got my house down here in
tennessee how important the window
treatments are to the way that the light
plays around in the house to the way you
feel all the time in that house go check
out hunterdouglas.com
knowles today for your free style get
smarter design guide with fresh takes
creative ideas and smart solutions for
dressing your windows that's hunter
douglas.com
knowles for your free design guide
dr fauci and the whole public health
establishment
are in an impossible little pickle right
now
which is
they are they are simultaneously forced
to argue two different things the new
message coming out of the public health
establishment is that you are going to
need to get a fourth
kovid shot
dr
can you talk a little bit more about
what you think the data show now of the
need for shot beyond the third dose
beyond
a booster as you know they're being
given
as early as five months we're
approaching five months uh now some of
the book first folks who dotted what do
we know about how often or if
further shots will be needed going
forward and in particular whether we
might need specific types of shots for
any variant
yeah thank you for that question that's
obviously an issue i think you should be
appreciative of the fact that when
you're talking about
any decisions that will be made and i'm
not anticipating any of that now but it
has to be put into the context
of whom you're talking about for example
there may be the need for yet again
another boost in this case a fourth dose
boost for an individual receiving the
mrna that could be based on age as well
as underlying conditions
now listen here we're not going to make
all of you get the fourth shot i mean
you've all got to get the third shot
which we initially told you you didn't
need but this we're not gonna make you
all get the fourth shot not this what
are we gonna hear in six months what are
we gonna hear we're you know what we're
gonna hear we're gonna hear all right
obviously everyone needs the fourth shot
get your little two-year-old kid the
fourth but we do not believe that
everyone needs the 15th shot okay only
the
immunocompromised need the 15. look i'm
not saying you all need the 25th shot
okay
only and it's going to go on and on and
on
because our economy now is geared
towards subscription models
so you know you sign up for your netflix
you sign up for your mlb tv and you sign
up for your pfizer and so just every so
often
you get you get your booster and that's
that's the way that it goes dr fauci has
to make an impossible sell right now
which is
the vaccines don't work so you need to
get the fourth shot because they didn't
work the first two didn't do what they
were supposed to do and then even the
third one didn't do what it was supposed
to do and so now you need the fourth one
and then it's going to do some of what
we told you it would do it's still not
going to do all of what we told you it
would do
namely stop transmission and stop
infection which i dr fauci and rochelle
wolenski and joe biden all said it was
going to do and then we admitted it
doesn't do
not just that
but you know at least if you get the
fourth shot maybe it'll reduce risk of
hospitalization and death maybe it will
okay so that's why you got to get the
fourth shot but also there are still a
lot of people who haven't even gotten
the first shot
and who are skeptical that the vaccines
are going to do what what we were all
told they were going to do and so at the
same time dr fauci's got to convince
them to get the first and second shot
because it's so effective that you've
got to go get that shot and it'll stop
you from getting the covid but also it's
not effective at all which is why you've
got to get the fourth shot and and
listen here peasant don't ask any
questions just go do it
well you gotta
why am i supposed to believe you on the
fourth shot if you were totally wrong on
the first three shots
don't stop asking those pesky questions
you you sound like a white supremacist
what what are you talking about you're a
far-right extremist like joe rogan hold
on what are you hold on calm down now
yeah you're probably smoking a lot of
crack which we're totally not sending
you well i think you were though you
were sending out the crack pipes anyway
anyway none of this is based on science
or logic or reason
what this is based on is
feelings and look a lot
my friend mr shapiro likes to say facts
don't care about your feelings but
politics largely cares about your
feelings so i'm not even dissing it okay
i'm not even saying that politicians
should not
seek to
in some way align their policy up with
the feelings of the people but this is
totally divorced from reality at this
point you're seeing this most clearly
with the head of the teacher union randy
weingarten who said
that policy about
masking and all the rest of it in
schools should be based not on the
science but on
feelings
the issue becomes how do we make sure
that the entire community in a school
feels safe and welcome and i don't think
that we there's when you get to covid
there's no no risk the real issue
becomes how do we make sure that
everybody feels safe so if we don't have
a mass mandate in school we gotta make
sure that kids and teachers are not
stigmatized for wearing masks and we
better do everything we can to make sure
the ventilation
is working in
in classrooms so that there's fresh air
and and that we're doing everything in
our power to make sure that this virus
is not transmissible
so you want to do everything in your
power to make sure the virus is not
transmissible so what you're going to
force people to wear cloth masks liana
wu even a leftist the medical
expert on cnn she came out and she said
that the cloth masks are just facial
ornamentation
they don't really do any of that
well we've got to get the vaccine
numbers up well we were just told by
fauci and wallensky and
biden that the vaccine does not stop
transmission so why are we focused on
getting the vaccine numbers up when it's
not going to do that
when it's not well because we need to
make people feel
comfortable we need to make them feel
safe right but those feelings are
completely divorced from reality
if you if you really want people to feel
comfortable and safe and to be
comfortable and safe
how about you tell them the truth
and how about we base our policy on the
truth they can't do that because they
are caught in so many lies
they are caught in so many lies
on this issue in particular
but
at the at the broader political level on
a whole number of issues that they can't
do it
they can't go back
they can't go back and ground their
policy in the truth the problem is that
people have been
deluded
and
covid and the masks that's just one
symptom of this but it's a really clear
symptom and it's a really clear symbol
the the mask is a political symbol and
it is a symbol of people's delusions
so well you know they we've got to make
sure that they wear that so that they
can remain in their delusion no that's
if you're going to
dispel delusion any place it should be
in a classroom that's the point of
education is to dispel fantasies to
dispel
illusions and to teach people the truth
but we can't do we're pretty far gone at
this point as some of us predicted we
would be there's a study that just came
out from the economist and yougov that
asked people how often do you wear your
mask when you leave the home they're
assuming now that people don't wear
their masks in the home i guess some
lunatics probably still do but they said
how many of you wear the mask now when
you leave the home
38
of respondents
38
said that they always wear the mask when
they leave their homes now now in in the
year of our lord 2022 two years after 15
days to slow the spread they are
wearing their masks which the public
health officials have admitted to us our
facial decorations don't really do much
of anything they've changed the argument
for the masks multiple times the masks
do not work they won't they won't do it
you during the height of a pandemic dr
fauci said this you shouldn't wear the
mask it's not people are going to fiddle
it's not going to give you that kind of
protection you think you're getting then
he said you do need to wear the masks
then they said the masks are to protect
other people now we're also being told
the masks are intended to protect
individuals sometimes but everyone's
really mealy-mouthed and confused about
it and then we're being told that the
masks actually don't do really much of
anything at all
and
the
official narrative on what the masks do
changes by the minute
and the and people will just go along
with it
one because they're legitimately
confused and two because they'll be
punished if they contradict whatever the
narrative is du jour if they contradict
whatever the party line is the people
pushing this crap don't believe it
gavin newsom doesn't believe it that's
why he keeps getting caught not wearing
his mask at public events
and in restaurants and in stadiums where
he tells other people to wear the masks
the mayor of san francisco multiple
times gets caught not wearing a mask
indoors at bars at clubs and she doesn't
even apologize she says oh well yeah the
spirit moved me i wanted to get up and
dance you don't want to dance with a
mask on okay all you peasants need to
put your mask on dr fauci how many times
has he been caught not wearing his mask
he walks into the center of an empty
baseball stadium he's got the mask on
he's making he's making an example and
then he goes and sits down next to his
friends and he takes the mask off not
even just to eat or drink he just takes
it off because it's uncomfortable and
stupid
so of course he's gonna stacy abrams
walks into a classroom she says all you
little kids who face statistically
almost no risk from this virus you all
need to put the mask on but not me not
stacy
and then they catch her in it and she
says oh i just took it off for a brief
second and then you see more photos of
her at other times not wearing the mask
in the classroom and she says oh yeah
well never mind actually her first
answer on this was if you criticize me
it's because you're a racist
our opponents are using a black history
month event to attack me it's pathetic
it's transparent you say no lady the
only thing that's pathetic and
transparent is is your insistence that
everyone follows a rule that you
yourself do not follow and do not
believe in
now something that i really believe in
is ordering your auto parts online from
rock auto in the year of our lord 2022
why are you going to the brick and
mortar auto parts store why are you
taking the time to get in your car drive
the 15 minutes go and wait online go
talk to the guy get peppered with
questions he goes in the back to look
for the part that you want for your car
a truck they don't have it he comes back
he says we're going to have to order it
come back in two weeks you drive home
you god why why
gosh why are you doing that when you can
go to rockauto.com
right now family business they got all
the parts for your car truck that you
could possibly want you could save 30
you could save 50
off the part the very same part that you
get in the brick and mortar store you
get it the website is so easy to
navigate even i can do it no gimmicks
it's not that you got to log in tuesday
morning at 11 a.m to save 15 no it's
always reliably low prices same prices
for pros and do-it-yourselfers go to
rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles k-n-w-l-e-s
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
stacey abrams
who was caught not wearing the mask at
this event with all the little kids that
she made mask up her initial reaction
was to double down say who cares call
her opponents racist typical leftist
playbook
but it's it's gone far enough even for
her and she's trying to get elected in
georgia
after spending several years pretending
that she got elected last time as
governor even though she lost that race
gaslighting a whole bunch of people on
the 2018 gubernatorial election so
stacey abrams said okay fine i'm going
to apologize
sort of
so obviously we've all seen the picture
we've all seen the coverage of the
picture
did you make a mistake by taking a photo
mask list in the classroom when it
appears that everyone else including all
the children were wearing them
yes i will say this i went to read to
kids for an african-american read-in day
i
approached the podium with my mask on i
followed the protocols i told the kids
i'm taking my mask off because i'm
reading to kids who are listening
remotely as well and we were socially
distanced the kids were socially distant
from me i told them that's what i was
doing and then the excitement after i
finished because it was so much fun
working with those kids i took a picture
and that was a mistake protocols matter
and protecting our kids is the most
important thing and anything that can be
perceived as undermining that is a
mistake and i apologize
i
apologize i mean i did nothing wrong and
i was just reading to kids and then i
only took my mask off because i was i
was reading to people over zoom and for
some reason people in the room can't can
hear you when you speak through a mask
but people can't hear you through a
microphone or whatever i guess that's
the argument i'm making and then i'm
sorry that i got so excited reading to
kids so you know i'm sort of sorry
not much of an apology stacey abrams
but she's trying to wriggle out of this
political dilemma that she's in having
learned absolutely nothing not caring at
all not believing in the covid alarmism
that she herself is helping to peddle
she's obviously not believing in it
because actions speak louder than words
but she's trying to wriggle out of it
there's a there's a yiddish expression
i'm not going to try to do it i don't
know what it is in yiddish but the
yiddish expression is if you're going to
eat pork eat it until your mouth drips
and the idea being if you're going to
transgress a moral law or a social more
you better enjoy yourself well you
better make it worthwhile to yourself
and
probably it would have been
wiser for stacey abrams to do that and
say look i own it i'm act i'm sorry i
did something very wrong i'm not going
to make excuses i'm not going to give
you explanations i just you caught me i
did something wrong you caught me i
shouldn't have done it
she can't do that
a republican in the same situation
if he wanted to wriggle out of it would
would i guess probably have to do that
kind of apology
he wouldn't be led off the hook with the
stacey abrams fake apology
but stacey abrams can get away with this
because
the entire establishment is working with
her and they're a propaganda arm for the
democratic party and they'll just change
the narrative day by day
speaking of selfish
lady celebrities
kim kardashian
i i have not talked about this story too
much because it's sort of tabloid trash
and the dissolution of a celebrity
marriage is neither particularly notable
news nor really any of my business or
interest
but i'll tell you
i i was really hoping those two kids
would make it
i was i know i know it's weird because
you know kim kardashian is a reality tv
porn star and she got her start on this
porn tape and kanye west is one of the
most eccentric
rappers and individuals in the entire
world but i just kind i kind of thought
i was hoping they would make it
and kanye west he had this conversion
experience
he became quite serious ostensibly about
his christianity and i just thought i
thought it'd be really good if they
could make it
but kim kardashian has said she's chosen
herself there's a seven bazillion word
profile of her now in one of the
magazines what is it vogue i guess
and in it she says i've chosen myself
quote for so long
i did what made other people happy the
41 year old explains and i think in the
last two years i decided i'm gonna make
myself happy and that feels really good
and even if that created changes and
caused my divorce i think it's important
to be honest with yourself about what
really makes you happy i've chosen
myself i think it's okay to choose you
she pauses before elaborating my 40s are
about being team me i'm going to eat
well i'm going to work out i'm going to
have more fun spend more time with my
kids and the people who make me happy
i'm going to put my phone down it's just
it's about me
and it yeah maybe that's going to cause
the dissolution of my marriage and yeah
maybe that's going to traumatize my
children and yeah maybe that's going to
cause just horrible problems for
everyone who whom i ostensibly love but
you know
i just kind of wanna i just kind of
wanna and that's really good and
important right be selfish it's really
good to be selfish so says the moral
philosopher kim kardashian
she has no right to do this this is
horribly reckless this is terrible for
her children it's wrong to do this in
her marriage it's just wrong it's just
wrong everything about it is wrong and i
bring it up not just to shame kim
kardashian but because so many people
believe this in our culture they just
think i've got it i'm so put upon i do
so much for everybody else what are you
talking about lady you are a celebrity a
reality tv star celebrity your your
entire career is about being
self-obsessed and so you've been
self-obsessed for your whole life and
now you're being more self-obsessed and
you're pretending that that's a change
which it's not and you're pretending
it's a change for the better which it
wouldn't be even if it were true
it's you're just doing more of what
you've been doing the whole time and
it's leading you to ever more
destructive
ever more destructive behaviors
so this is a great way to live a
miserable life
i'm i'm very sad that kim yay seems to
be splitting up but let this be
a cautionary tale let this there's
there's a woman right now she was from
the at t commercials i haven't seen a
lot of them but she's the the lady from
the the at t commercials milana vaintrub
she just wrote in this long essay about
how happy she is to have aborted her
child
she said over the past decade i've
hardly thought about my abortion except
for when i think of those who may not
have access to one she's saying i'm not
upset about my abortion i don't even
think about it i don't that's why i'm
writing long essays about it it's
because i totally don't think about it
and it had no effect and it was totally
a trivial event because now that i've
experienced a full-term pregnancy and
given birth i find myself thinking about
how imprisoning it would be to go
through this if i didn't choose it
a spoiler alert by the way 99 plus of
women who get abortions choose it they
choose to get pregnant because they've
had consensual sex all of us with a
uterus may soon be stripped of the
constitutional right to an abortion it's
awful here we are
i wouldn't have had my career
i wouldn't have had all of this if i
hadn't killed my child i couldn't have
sold cell phones on television
i couldn't have had the supreme joy of
selling
cellular telephone plans on tv
if i had not killed my child it's a it's
a horrific thing
i am i assume this is a completely fake
front and she actually is deeply
troubled by this which is why she keeps
talking about it
but think about what what madness a
culture has to descend into and a person
has to descend into to think that
selling
crappy cell phones on television
is
so much better than
having a child and it justifies killing
a child that's the mad sort of culture
we're living in and we've all got to
we've all got to pretend that it's true
in this gaslighting culture if you
missed the world premiere of shut-in
last night then you seriously missed out
not only did we get to share a film too
gritty and thrilling for hollywood but
we were able to tease out our next big
film terror on the prairie that's a
western starring the great gina carano
we could not be more excited to be
making good on our promise of bringing
you real entertainment and for those
that tuned in we seriously hope you
enjoyed as much as we did if you missed
it
do not worry it's streaming on our
website for members only if you're not a
member head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe enter code shut in for 30 off
your membership we will be right back
with the mailbag
my favorite time of the week the mailbag
first question up from ava hi michael in
a previous mailbag you mentioned that
yoga is satanic and i was wondering how
you feel about holistic healing and
organic food recently my mom switched us
over from taking pills and going to the
doctor to juicing fruit and using
essential oils and plants on one hand i
feel better drinking fresh pineapple
juice and rubbing peppermint oil on my
lips than swallowing cough syrup on the
other hand i jokingly tell her she's
being a hippie and we shouldn't practice
witchcraft
ava great job
you got the right attitude what is your
view on holistic healing and organic
food
do you think it's witchcraft or
something we should all do being that
the medical and pharmaceutical companies
are becoming less and less trustworthy
sincerely an organic apple a day can
keep fouchy away if you just throw it
hard enough
ava i don't need to give you any advice
you clearly have a good head on your
shoulders you've got to parse out a
couple of things here
just just as with the yoga example by
the way is yoga bad to do well there's
two parts to yoga there's the physical
part
and the spiritual part the religious
part and most people pretend that yoga
is entirely physical it's just
stretching what's wrong with wearing
tight pants and stretching michael
but they ignore the fact that you're
doing chants you're doing a hindu
liturgy you're i mean you're actually
participating in a religious ritual and
so if you
are a christian or you're not
a
hindu who practices yoga that would seem
to be incoherent and if you are a
christian for instance if you're a
monotheist
then you probably shouldn't be
practicing a
polytheistic religious liturgy that's
probably not not a great idea well it's
the same thing here with all the hippie
food sweet little elisa loves the hippie
food now she's totally into it i can't
believe it
me sweet alisa's been gone the past few
days and so i've just been eating
absolute trash fast food for almost
every meal i've got
wrappers in the back of my car from
every fast food joint you can imagine i
just i don't really care about the
organic
you know but sweet little alisa will go
to the grocery store and not only will
she get the organic egg now which you
know a regular egg is what like two or
three bucks for a dozen
the the organic egg is what it's like
fifteen hundred dollars per egg and then
but it's not just that it's she's going
to get the pasture raised
organic
you know filet mignon fed
college educated
a you know living in a nice uh condo in
tribeca egg
and that's gonna and that's gonna cost
me my annual salary per omelet to do it
but she's really into it and she says
the eggs look better and frankly i i
like the idea
of not trusting big farming and not
trusting big pharma for that matter and
not trusting these you know giant woke
corporations that
that do not have our interests at heart
and and sure i'm i'm actually all for
really high quality food but then you
said holistic healing there too
meaning what is that are you like
chanting things are you in addition to
just eating high quality foods are you
now also
taking a bunch of snake oil and doing
all sorts of kooky hippy rituals that
part you should not do i'm all for
stretching i'm not for worshiping demons
i'm all for eating nice eggs even if
they're fancy and they're going to
bankrupt me i'm not for engaging in
rituals that are
not going to help you medically
and that are spiritually very confused
you we can do both prudence and
moderation are virtues
temperance is a virtue
so
it can be the case that
when when you've got a legitimate
illness you take real medicine but also
you don't trust everything that big farm
is trying to shove down your throat and
also maybe you eat a little bit better i
think a little temperance in moderation
is a good idea and i i do hope that
sweet little elisa every so often
starts buying the regular eggs as well
so that we can continue to pay our
mortgage from jake dear lord knowles
i've heard your arguments for capital
punishment and the execution of certain
criminals by the state i agree with you
however i would go a step further and be
in favor of inhumane public televised
executions
okay
rather than dzhokhar tsarnaev of the
boston marathon bomber or lee boyd malvo
the dc beltway sniper attack
or dylan roof who is actually the only
one sentenced to death he was the guy
who shot up a black church and killed
lots of innocent people given special
privileges for the muslim faith life in
prison or private execution
i think a live burning at the stake
would be more useful i believe the
thought of suffering a similar fate
would be much more effective in
deterring wannabes than the risk of
living being famous in a compound with
all the essentials taken care of and the
inevitable book being made about your
infamous deeds what are your thoughts on
this and is this a bit too far
it is a bit too far
it is because
the
the reason to support capital punishment
is not
your desire for vengeance that would be
a very bad reason it's not your desire
for wrath
it's not your desire to torture someone
the good argument for capital punishment
is justice
and justice
is different than vengeance and justice
is different than wrath
just here's an example of justice an eye
for an eye
like we see in the bible
here's an example of
vengeance and wrath and injustice
if you pluck out my eye i will kill your
entire family and burn your town to the
ground that would be that would not be
proportionate
that would not be particularly just
a good argument for capital punishment
is
is not we want to hurt you and put you
in as much pain as we possibly can a
good argument for capital punishment is
we want to help you actually because
hanging concentrates the mind and you're
a sick puppy and society has the right
to protect itself against you and
society has the right to deter further
crime and justice calls out and demands
justice it demands itself it demands
that everyone gets what he deserves
but also
[Music]
we're doing you a favor we we don't want
you to persist down this terrible path
we want you to repent we want you to
get your get your soul in order before
you meet your maker so i would not
would not recommend you know burning
people alive necessary it's it's i don't
think that would be the best argument i
don't think that would bring a lot of
people along either from cameron michael
hello from very liberal illinois the
good news is that the district i live in
has a republican representative the bad
news is the representative is adam
kinzinger my question is when his name
comes on the ballot next time should i
still give him my vote if he is facing a
democrat either way it feels like a
lose-lose yeah it does kinzinger is such
a putts i mean he's just such a
squish
fake conserve court jester conservative
who lives
and exists to serve democrats and to
give the pretense of genuine opposition
all of that said the way to get rid of
kinzinger and the other squishes is to
primary them that's that's when you can
do it so someone should run against him
in a primary i don't think he's even
running for reelection is he there's no
way that guy's gonna win again so that's
that's the way you would do it as you
would primary them but if you're asking
me just generally take kinzinger out of
it for a second
if if i live in a liberal place
and the choice is between a leftist
democrat and a moderate republican who
should i vote for
i think you should vote for the most
right viable candidate that's the
buckley rule
rules have exceptions sure but i think
that's a good guide
you should vote for the most right
viable there are some benefits
to electing squishes it'd be better to
elect conservatives but the the benefits
to electing squishes in left-wing places
left-wing states and left-wing districts
is you can preserve say a republican
majority
you can you can get generally better
policy
so you've got to make a prudential
judgment there but ideally you boot the
guy out in the primaries and you get a
real conservative from lauren
hi michael i've been in a strict
quarantine since the pandemic began and
have only left my house a handful of
times in two years i'm 24 living with my
parents where one has health conditions
making it extremely high risk for covid
causing us to be cautious
i'm not just a bum only child living off
of my parents i moved back after college
to save money and the pandemic hit
before i could move because of this
isolation i've gone through lots of
anxiety and depression but have tried to
stay focused on the fact that my
sacrifices have been for my family and
the positives that have come like
finding this show that's very kind
i'm close with my family and do not want
to hurt feelings or show disrespect at
what point do i say i have fulfilled my
christian daughter duties and should
take steps to re-enter society when that
point comes how do i proceed without
being disrespectful or hurtful thank you
and god bless people pleaser from
nashville nashville my town too you're
my neighbor well you know nashville's
not locked down
it really never was locked down but
certainly not not locked down anymore
nashville is has been back to regular
life for for a long time so i i think
that if your parent is genuinely at very
high risk from covid and if the vaccines
for whatever reason cannot be expected
to work on your parent and and if you've
taken all these precautions and still
your parent is at extreme risk
at a certain point you've got to get
back to living life i'm not saying you
should never have acquiesced and
sacrificed some of your individual
liberty to your parent no actually
that's a good and
pious thing to do it's great
but
you got to move on then you've got to
move on either
your parent misunderstands the science
and is relying on a cloth mask to save
them and the cloth mask is not going to
save them or
doesn't think that the vaccine is even
going to prevent hospitalization or
death or greatly reduce that risk which
we're all told that that's still what
the vaccine does so maybe they're
misunderstanding that or you know if
your parent is living in delusion and
neurosis from covid then it would be
good to gently correct your parent on
that but uh regardless
you probably have to move out at some
point
and you can we have a labor shortage i'm
sure you can get a job if you don't have
one already and
you know you've you got to move on then
you can't you can't be trapped in a
tower in your parents home even if they
have every good reason to not let you go
out or you know it's their house and to
force you to wear a mask or whatever
at a certain point you have to live your
life and it's not a rejection of your
family to say okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
move out now and live on my own
in part to help protect you from this
medical condition but you you have to do
that's
you gotta you gotta live you can't
you can't just hide for your whole life
that's not
you can't and get more anxious and more
and more depressed and i'm glad that my
show can
provide some relief from your anxiety
and depression but i say this with no
false modesty i am not enough my dear
you've got to go you've got to go live
your life from joe hi michael four
months ago my wife and i welcomed our
first child into the world my new role
of father has changed my outlook on many
things including a desire to return to
my catholic roots i was born and raised
catholic
my wife though not hostile toward the
catholic church has no desire to convert
or have our son baptized in the faith
we've come to the agreement that we
alter will alternate sundays between the
non-denominational protestant service
and mass holy catholic mass and allow
our son to choose his faith
when he desires what are your thoughts
on this thanks for the advice
well you know my thoughts
for as a religious matter because i'm
catholic
and my thoughts are you should obviously
baptize your child and raise him in the
catholic faith now maybe your wife says
no i totally reject that no way i'm not
gonna do that okay she i guess she's
entitled to her religious views but
that's a you problem then and you've got
to figure this out the one thing i would
not do
is split the baby
do not split the baby that's not a good
idea
you cannot raise your child
simultaneously in two different
religions you can't if your kid is going
to be a catholic then your kid is not
going to be a protestant and if your kid
is going to be a protestant your kid is
not going to be a catholic and you can
try to kick the can down the road and
you can try to ignore it and bury your
head into the stand and say well no you
know it's and even if you say well we're
going to do both then that just means
your kid's a protestant because
the protestant churches regardless of
which denomination you're in
the the one unifying feature is they're
all not catholic so if and if you're a
catholic they say don't you can't
participate in other religious
ceremonies so you are even if you think
that you're just persisting in a kind of
indecision you are making a decision
that indecision is a type of decision
and so you gotta you gotta pick it i
don't know it's your marriage i can't
answer and it's your faith and it's you
know your relationship with god so
you've got to make that decision
but if it were me i would say
in my true knuckle-dragging troglodyte
sort of way i would say my dear
we're married i'm the head of this
household we're raising the child
catholic
and uh
i'm not gonna force you to uh you know
i'm not gonna force you to convert if
you don't want to convert but we are
baptizing the child we're raising him in
the sacraments and that's the way it
goes
and you know by the way if you're i
don't know what sort of
protestant views your wife has
but you know some of them are pretty
into that whole genesis 3 like i'm the
head of my household sort of thing so
maybe look maybe that'll work maybe
maybe it'll be persuasive but i would
make a decision don't pretend that you
can get away from me you can't you can't
you've gotta you are making a decision
one way or the other you can't avoid it
from evan hello mr knowles you recently
answered a question from a viewer
regarding a woman a woman's body count
okay
you know talking about a woman's uh
sexual history since most women won't be
honest about their number should men be
honest about their pasts would it be
considered lying to tell the truth
but not the whole truth i don't think a
relationship filled with secrecy can be
successful
as the truth will eventually come out
thank you for your advice
for men or for women
you should not lie about this
and frankly if you've amended your ways
you know and repented and you know kind
of changed your life you don't even need
to be all that ashamed of your of your
past you know in the course of justice
none of us should see salvation
and we have the opportunity for
redemption and repentance we've all done
terrible things and all fall short of
the glory of god and you can just move
on so okay move on
uh you don't you don't want to lie about
that would be really bad but the other
thing is yeah we love
transparency in our culture we think
nothing is better than just complete
transparency over anything
a little mystery is okay too i don't
want to hear
about every single thing in excruciating
detail
that my
girlfriend or wife or
[Music]
you know if you're a lady writing in a
boyfriend or husband i want to hear
about every single detail of everything
they've ever done a little mystery is
just fine don't be dishonest do not lie
but
modesty and discretion is okay too i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show we'll see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin